[Music]
first off thank you for walking over
from Moscone many of you I'm very happy
to be talking today about Google's
newest manage database offering cloud
sequel as of today is announcing support
for Postgres which has been one of our
most requested enhancements so it's nice
to be able to answer yes to that
question starting today what we're gonna
talk about of course is cloud sequel for
Postgres I'll do some focusing on
certain features that are in the beta
product and then we'll also look ahead
cloud sequel for Postgres is a beta
product which means we're just getting
started you're gonna see us deliver new
features during the beta program and
I'll talk about a few of those today
after that we'll invite Tim Kelton who
is co-founder and cloud architect at
decart labs tim has been an early
adopter of cloud sequel for Postgres and
generally has used Postgres for many
years to build some really stunning
geospatial applications Tim will walk us
through how decart is using Google cloud
to build these applications and
hopefully show off one as well and then
we'll get into some next steps and
things that hopefully you can take away
before we jump into all of that I have a
few questions for you by show of hands
how many of you in the audience are
developers so we've got call it two
thirds how about database administrators
how about reluctance database
administrators aha there's a few more
hands and lastly any managers in the
audience one brave soul maybe two thank
you how many of you are using Postgres
today or use it frequently it's about
half the room and how many of you in the
audience last question here for now our
cloud sequel users not nearly as many
okay great well I think we're gonna have
a little something for everyone in the
audience and we'll jump right in let me
start by saying that cloud sequel is
launching post rest and when I say that
if you're all in your laptops right now
and you go to cloud console click on
cloud sequel you won't see post rest yet
in the console where
launching it as we speak which means
some of you today and tomorrow will
begin to see it in your console many of
you over this coming weekend will see it
in your console and all of you by early
next week will see Postgres in your
console and be able to create instances
that said all of you today with the CLI
or an API can create a cloud sequel for
Postgres instance right now so I based
on the response from the room I don't
have to go into the merits of Postgres
but I think many of you using Postgres
right now see that it's a powerful open
source relational database really a
vibrant open source community backing it
with many years of active development
and in addition to strong standards
compliance I think the the one of the
most unique features about Postgres is
the fact that it is extensible and we'll
be talking today specifically about one
extension post GIS which adds powerful
object or geospatial objects support to
Postgres so where does cloud sequel fit
in Google's fairly broad and growing
database portfolio on this slide right
most you see Google's data warehousing
product bigquery again rightmost column
we store objects in clouds in cloud
storage or GCS we have non-relational no
sequel databases in cloud datastore and
BigTable finally get to the relational
space where cloud sequel lives along
with spanner and if you haven't taken a
look at spanner yet or been to some of
the talks about spanner going on at the
conference I would encourage you to do
so and then farthest over on the Left we
have our in-memory products in memcache
for App Engine so you get a kind of a
feel for where cloud sequel is broadly
in the database portfolio the thing I'll
note about cloud sequel is that cloud
sequel delivers standard my sequel and
now Postgres databases which means if
you have an application running with
Postgres today with few exceptions your
application will run immediately with
cloud sequel we're not offering CLEP
Postgres compatibility layers we're
offering standard Postgres and standard
my sequel the other thing I'll say about
cloud sequel is it is not a DBA we do
our best to offload the more mundane
database administration
installing databases patching them
setting up backups but we are not a DBA
in the sense that cloud sequel won't
optimize queries etc as we look at
running databases in Google Cloud or
on-prem I think the thing you'll hear me
kind of repeat in this presentation is
cloud sequel is a managed database
service it's important I think to
distinguish what exactly that means
so let's do this by just taking a look
at what it takes to run a database and
we'll start with the hardware layer
folks in the audience who are running on
Prem are thinking today about power and
cooling even if you're not even if you
go into a Colo or hosting provider or a
cloud vendor I would encourage you to
think about server maintenance here in
Google Cloud part of our server
maintenance is live migration with
compute engine cloud sequel benefits
from that feature and if you aren't
aware of it there's been a few great
blog posts put out by the compute engine
team on live migration obviously server
maintenance whether you are maintaining
your servers or not has major
implications for your application stack
so then we look at the operating system
on top of the servers and this is where
we reach a fork in the road this is the
first place where if I'm deciding should
I self host a database on Google cloud
for example or go to a managed database
product like cloud sequel we start to
see some real differences if you're self
managing a database you're going to
install your operating system you're
going to maintain it with patches etc
cloud sequel you won't see the operating
system we maintain it for you it's not
even exposed of course when you're self
managing a database you're gonna do the
database install you're gonna patch it
keep it up-to-date you're going to set
up database backups in the cloud sequel
or the managed world we're doing that
again for you were turning on automatic
backups if you'd like us to or pruning
those as we go along and we've also
taken care of the software patches etc
lastly we'll look at the advanced
features high availability if you're
self managing for to get high
availability you are setting up
replication between Postgres databases
for example you've built tooling that
monitors the health of these databases
and you are alerting so that you can
manually failover in the case of some
outage or you've built additional
scripts etc to failover automatically in
the manage database space
with cloud sequel cloud sequel takes
care of high availability for you in
that it sets up the replication we do
the monitoring and actually trigger the
fail overs the other thing here is in
the managed world you are backed by
Google's team in the self-managed world
you are backing the database
availability itself last item on the
slide is scaling in a self-managed world
you decide when to scale up when to
scale out and you implement those in the
managed world I want to make special
note here cloud sequel helps you scale
more easily we help you scale up easily
help you scale out easily but unlike
other database products in our portfolio
cloud sequel does not auto scale so it's
up to you still as an administrator to
decide it's time to scale up or it's
time to scale out one thing that we
shouldn't forget is monitoring and
monitoring goes beyond just application
level kind of monitoring stack driver
for example and this this can be
something like I want to make sure that
my slow query logs get to pub/sub or to
cloud logging for easy ingestion by
third party apps like Splunk for example
with a managed service a lot of this
plumbing is set up for you self manage
is not now I'm the cloud sequel product
manager so I was I have some bias here
in terms of manage databases my point
here is not to say that one is
necessarily better than the other
um you all are making trade-offs during
your day you're deciding I'm gonna spend
more time in this piece of my technology
stack to make sure it is customized to
exactly what I want and as a trade-off
I'm going to spend more time managing
that piece of the stack I think the
decision between a self managing
databases and managed database service
like cloud sequel is very much that you
will lose customization or flexibility
when you go to the managed world but you
gain all these offloading of what we
call mundane tasks the self managed
world you can tune Postgres to your
heart's content but you are managing
that database and managing its uptime
hope that gives you a good sense for how
we break down difference between self
managing and managing databases and
again I'm happy to say that cloud sequel
now gives you the option to do this with
Postgres so let me highlight just a few
features for you as a starting point
cloud sequel for Postgres offers large
instance sizes up
to 32 cores and more than 200 gigabytes
of RAM you can see in the screenshot
here we are showing the fact that we're
using custom VMs as the underlying
mechanism to cloud sequel which means
you get granularity with respect to a
number of CPU cores size of RAM on your
instance type the other thing I'll note
is we have inexpensive development
instances our smallest instances start
at less than $10 a month so you can get
going with with Postgres very affordably
for example next feature I'll talk about
is storage
I think it's intuitive for us to scale a
database in terms of CPUs and RAM a
little less intuitive as scaling
performance in terms of storage and the
thing I'll note here is that at Google
we scale storage performance by scaling
capacity so as you add capacity you get
more performance what you're seeing here
built into the cloud sequel instance
creation form that'll be coming live to
your console soon is we see the
performance calculator on the bottom and
what it's showing you is this is the
performance level you can expect based
on the number of CPU cores you've
selected and the size of your storage in
this case you can see I am NOT maxing
out the IEEE ops I could get out of my
instance if I were to add capacity you
would see that slider bar ratchet up all
the way to in this case 25 thousand I
ops there's a small check box next to a
one-liner in our create form that I
think is really important and it's our
auto storage increase feature so when
you check this box you can see enable
auto storage increase that tells Google
you deal with my storage capacity as I
get near my 10 gigabyte limit or 400
gigabyte limit in this case increase
storage capacity for me automatically
and the nice thing about Google
persistent disk storage is that we can
increase the storage weather capacity
performance both as a hot operation you
don't take your database down so if you
check that box you leave the storage
capacity management to us we will
automatically grow your storage as you
need it while your database is running
next feature is backups that are
included with cloud sequel for Postgres
you can enable automatic backups which
get taken daily
you tell us what time of day you want
those backups taken we automatically
prune those after seven days we'll get
rid of your oldest back up and take the
newest so you get a rolling 7-day
automatic back up you can also take
on-demand backups these are manual
backups that you control yourself you
decide when to take them and you decide
how long to retain them if you want to
retain one for a year or three years or
seven years you can do so we keep them
as long as you want with respect to
maintenance I talked about maintenance
in that decision between self managing
and managing database with respect to
maintenance we offer a maintenance
window you tell us day a week and time
of day and we'll make sure that any
maintenance we do is performed in that
window you also tell us maintenance
timing so if you have to post rests
database instances in a given project
you might say I would like my
development instance to be maintained or
updated before my production instance
and you can use the maintenance timing
field here which is earlier and later to
decide that my development instance
should be updated before my production
instance and when you do that you get
yourself about a week of difference
between these two things
so something on the earlier track will
get updated one week before something on
the later pad track is is our general
guidance on maintenance timing the last
point I'll mention here is extensions
and I think part of Postgres is
uniqueness and its its power is in its
extension ecosystem we've included a
handful of extensions at the beta launch
we expect this list to grow over time
and we'll look for your feedback and the
extension we wanted to make sure we got
into the product for launch as post GIS
it's one of the most frequently used
extensions for Postgres and it's always
used by folks like yourself who are
interested in geospatial applications so
what's next I told you that this is a
beta product and we're just getting
started
it means during the CES land large
features during the beta period so
what's not included today things around
replication are not included today so
for example we don't yet offer high
availability nor do we offer read scale
out with regret because those things are
coming we offer backup
in recovery but we don't yet offer
point-in-time recovery again that's
another one that's coming and from a
connectivity point of view today cloud
sequel for Postgres supports connections
from compute engine from App Engine
flexible environment which just went GA
from container engine or generally from
any client that supports a standard
Postgres connector that said we don't
yet support connectivity from cloud
functions which was announced at this
conference nor do we yet support
connectivity from App Engine standard so
you got a few things to look forward to
as part of this beta period and to keep
in mind as you start to use the product
so I have another set of questions for
you and I will ask you all by show of
hands and we'll be on the honor system
you get one vote if you're telling us
what to do next which of these five
features is most important to you so
again honor system you get one vote how
many of you say I want you Google to do
high availability next got about I'll
call it a third of the room all right
how about read replicas this is read
scale out accountant Tim's vote as well
another third of the room connectivity
from App Engine standard one brave soul
cloud functions connectivity a couple
folks couple folks are excited about
that one and lastly point in time
recovery I'm going to assume all of you
are worried about recovery but are just
not voting it above these other features
okay so it looks like the replication
features where our hottest commodity I
appreciate that feedback in if you do
have questions as we go along keep them
in mind Tim and I are going to leave
some time at the end and we've got mics
so that we'll be able to answer your
questions okay so it's one thing to talk
just about a product I think where this
gets exciting is how you put a product
like this together with other
technologies to build a great
application and I'm excited to say that
Tim Kelton who is the co-founder of
decart labs is here with us today Tim
and the cart Labs have been an early
adopter of cloud sequel for Postgres
they participated in a private alpha
program Tim and the team at the cart
have put together Postgres with post GIS
and a number of products
Google cloud to build some outstanding
geospatial applications and I ask you
all to join me in welcoming Tim thanks
thanks Brett today I'd like to share
with you how some of the geospatial
features that Brett just mentioned are
helping us at Descartes Labs focus on
the really hard problems we're trying to
solve and less on the day-to-day
managing and scaling of infrastructure
so what are those heart what are those
hard problems Descartes Labs applies
machine learning and AI to global
satellite and aerial imagery to see how
the earth changes every day and our goal
is to help customers quantify and
predict how those changes will affect
them in our first products looked at
things like how much food are we
producing in North America and we built
a platform on Google cloud initially to
to answer those questions such as
agriculture but we've since found as a
range of applications in areas such as
security and trading but also in supply
chain and logistics you see okay so
Descartes Labs was founded in December
of 2014 we are Silicon Valley backed and
we have Silicon Valley veteran
leadership and that's where the story
changes were not the stereotypical
Silicon Valley startup myself and the
rest of the founding team were
researchers engineers and scientists
high up in the mountains of northern New
Mexico at Los Alamos National Laboratory
and there we focused on areas such as
deep learning remote sensing and
large-scale high performance computing
and today we have nearly 30 employees
and relevant to this talk we have no DBA
is on staff
so how do we find Google cloud it's a
little bit different story that maybe
typically as a early-stage startup we
couldn't just go spend millions and
millions of dollars buying satellite
imagery and the earth engine team at
Google actually provided a public data
set called NASA from NASA called Landsat
and Landsat was launched in 1973 and has
been continuously observing the earth
since then and so that is available on
natively on Google Cloud storage in a
just a cloud storage bucket you can just
simply GS util LS and see all of the
imagery there so we started in the early
months of the company started pulling
imagery down to VMs on Google Cloud and
building small scale models over very
limited geographical regions and over
very small time windows trying to do
something like forecast food production
in the United States it was quickly
apparent that when it worked so we
needed to scale up our processing coming
from places like Los Alamos where you
have high-performance supercomputing and
access to a lot of resources you're not
necessarily instantly confident that the
cloud will actually scale to the levels
you need it to and very quickly we knew
we would need to use models that would
cover large geographic regions such as
the entire United States and would see
many many years of crops growing you can
think here in California like two years
ago how what was the story it was all
droughts and and you know a bleak water
levels and this year we have reservoirs
dramatically overflowing so to to build
accuracy in these models we needed a
large window and so just a few months
into the company we were able to scale
up on Google cloud our code to process
that entire petabyte of Landsat and
Modi's imagery to process all of that in
just over 15 hours on 30,000 virtual
cores and that's the power of having
this data natively on the cloud
right next to compute and you know like
I said coming from places with
high-performance computing what we are
so pleasantly surprised with was not
just that we were able to get lots of
cores but also that storage was able to
scale with our needs and networking all
of those need to scale uniformly to
actually scale up and process that
amount of data really quickly so once we
had processed all of this data we were
able to build models over much larger
geographic regions such as the whole
United States and see daily changes as
new satellite imagery comes in every
single day in 2015 we had our first
models and when they got announced on
Bloomberg they actually moved the market
a few percent and we were all kind of
surprised and excited and then later in
2016 as most people that work in machine
learning are constantly trying to
improve the accuracy of the models we
improved our models we also started
working with customers on larger
geographic regions around the earth and
on adding multiple more multiple new
crops
additionally we now actually release our
models what we're predicting as far as
food supply on a mobile app so later in
in 2016 on Google Cloud the Earth engine
team made a second dataset publicly
available again natively on cloud
storage so this is just there you can go
in your browser very on your command
line and GS util LS this directory and
that's from the european space agency
that's the sentinel 2 data set so this
is petabytes of imagery that are
actually stored in Google Cloud and
Google is paying the bill for hosting
this imagery and so you can quickly just
start working on the actual problem
you're trying to solve today I want to
share with you a little more information
about the platform we've built on top of
Google Cloud and I want to show you a
product that we just launched on Tuesday
called geo visual search that we've
built on top of our platform so just a
high-level diagram of what our
platform consists of as I already
mentioned we have various datasets from
NASA and the US
NASA European Space Agency a number of
other public datasets and it's great
when they just live in the cloud but a
lot of these we actually need to pull in
and the sensors on satellites have been
launched over basically a decade or more
very tremendously they vary in the
amount of light bands that they capture
they vary in the sensor technology
that's used and our end goal is to make
a really common imagery API that we can
quickly have our machine learning teams
have a nice Python API around and no
matter which set of imagery or which
layers of light that it will be a really
uniform experience and so we have so you
can think of things more like a Python
API or a Jupiter notebook kind of
similar to data lab so our processing
how we start with ingesting all of this
imagery and we have to do things like go
register the imagery for really accurate
alignment we have to convert it to
standard projections things like
removing clouds here in San Francisco
and I'm not talking about compute clouds
I'm talking about like overhead clouds
which in San Francisco happen quite a
bit correct for shadows adjust for
camera angles angles of the Sun
calibrate the sensors against their
neighbors atmospheric reflectance all of
these things have to happen in our
initial processing pipeline and that
happens on compute engine using
primarily managed instance groups and we
heavily leveraged the preemptable
instances to cut down on costs in that
case because it's very embarrassing ly
parallel workload so then we we have
kind of two directions from our
processing pipeline where data goes our
imagery or what we call raster data
those are the pixels that gets stored
natively I think as Brett had a slide
that gets stored on
on cloud storage we know that cloud
storage we will not run out of space
we're expecting to have nearly 15
petabytes of imagery by the end of this
year we know that it will scale we know
that we can throw thousands of course
processing against it and it will handle
that and it's nothing we have to manage
so all of our compressed imagery gets
stored and this is on this left side of
the chart and then those services are
available via can microservices in front
of sitting on top of container engine
where we can query and pull down those
images really quickly the second part of
our imaging processing pipeline is is
more of the vector data as we see each
scene we capture pieces of information
about that scene and we use pub/sub to
persist that information into a post GIS
database these are things we need to
geospatially query and we and so post
GIS enables us a mechanism to do that
and cloud SQL supporting post just
starts giving us more of the freedom to
not do things like install geo Sanji
doll and proj 4j and Lib to XML just to
get things into a geospatial database
and so those are more of what we
consider vector data things like
polygons and points or given points of
data that we might use to train our
machine learning models say this given
geographic region what do we see the
values at that given time and then try
and train the models to correlate with
that so we have many sources of data
that we store in post GIS things like
public data from maybe the US Department
of Agriculture but also private datasets
sometimes from customers as well so then
both of those come together we host many
many micro services again on top of
either managed instance groups or on top
of gke and then that's where we are able
to do image searching image raster's
location-based searches and build models
on
top of that and finally one last theme
in the last six months I would say we've
started adopting stackdriver stackdriver
provides a nice uniform way to do
logging and we're gradually using the
alerting features more and more and we
can use that on things like preemptable
instances which come and go
things like logging is quite challenging
to figure out good solutions for but we
can also tie that into cloud pub/sub -
cloud SQL and - gke and we kind of have
a really common way of querying logs to
look at look for errors or latency
problems or just diagnose
code so what types of models do we
actually produce this is a little bit
more information on the agricultural
models I mentioned earlier and we
started doing this in 2015 just a few
months into our company how is this done
traditionally the US Department of
Agriculture will send surveys and they
send thousands of surveys out to
individual farmers a few times during
the growing season to get progress on
the actual growth of crops and then they
aggregate the surveys back and finally
release a number and then the market
moves how do we do it we have a quite
different approach we pull in about four
quadrillion pixels so you can think of
billions and billions of iPhone photos
and we see every field everywhere in the
earth every single day and those are
inputs into our models to basically
predict how much food will be produced
at the end of the year and so as I said
we've iterated on those models many
times and you can see in this chart this
graph we can show that we not only are
more accurate than the US Department of
Agriculture but we get that information
much earlier and we can see how things
like a big weather event like a
hailstorm in Iowa what was the actual
effect of that I should say in 2017 our
models will now be
back trained or back tested over the
last 13 years so we can go back 12 years
ago or five years ago and say how did
the model perform given this weather
parameter one really exciting advance is
we're now extending the use of these
models to do things like try and detect
early indications of a famine outbreak
so this is something in North Africa you
can think of things like political
instability that occur from food
shortage getting aid to places faster
and the amount of lives you can save
it's really exciting to be a part of
that so next I'd like to show you what
we just released on Tuesday something
called geo visual search and geo visual
search extends on top of the machine
learning platform that I was showing you
being able to do geospatial queries over
windows of time and pull it together
multiple different bands of light not
just always human visible bands such as
red green blue but also things like
infrared and build models and iterate on
models to see things that you could
never actually humanly hire enough
people to see as part of that we need
training data and we have many sources
of training data like I mentioned before
one of those that's open source is
OpenStreetMaps
we can use a area such as OpenStreetMaps
to train in a given geographic location
what are we actually seeing in these
images and then we use tensorflow to
build models and that as we processed
our imagery through there we determine
various signatures of each scene all
across the globe and then we try and see
where else in this in trillions and
trillions of pixels across the entire
earth where else do we see similar items
so this is a again we use pub/sub in
this scenario to persist that data but
this time we're persisting the model
results out into BigTable
and then finally using container engine
to serve the api's and the front-end
interface so as part of this talk I
thought I would just quickly show you
one problem I would have on it
traditionally using this approach again
things like OpenStreetMaps I'm just
trying to train a dataset it's a public
open source data set sometimes it's
accurate sometimes it's not
sometimes our models that will train out
of that aren't going to produce that
good of results and we'll need to try a
different approach so the end goal is
not to build a long production database
always it's to get a geospatial data set
in there so we can use it for training
and then move on to the next next models
so this is I don't know if anyone here
has had fun with OpenStreetMaps and
using the tool OSM 2pg SQL it's an
importer tool that lets you import all
of OpenStreetMaps
into a post GIS compatible database so
as you might be able to scroll down and
see all these fun messages after a few
hours of importing I took a 50 gig
compressed OpenStreetMaps file and it's
a 50 gig compressed XML file so it's
really hard to guess exactly how big
that's going to be in post post post GIS
and all of a sudden I get to the spot
where I have no disk space left on
device and I've wasted my time and I got
I need to now make a bigger VM with a
larger disk and try this again and maybe
I've guessed right the second time but
that's not that different than getting
requirements I don't know if any of you
have asked for requirements early on in
a project and you've received input and
either you never ever used any all the
space you asked for that was asked for
or you basically started way too small
and your project became wildly
successful and you needed to import all
these other data sets into the database
so one of the features Brett mentioned
was the auto growth so here's an example
of by clicking the auto growth or
selecting that in the API
we could start at with a 10 gig disk and
instantly grow and we grew over a few
hours to 380
it looks like 387 gigs and the awesome
part about this was I just am paying for
the amount of storage I actually need at
that given time
I'm not overestimating I'm not under
estimating and I know it can grow and
we're really excited about things like
Reid replicas and high availability as
well especially applying that to micro
services which sometimes SmartStart
really small but then get really really
useful as you add features so at this
point I would like to switch over to the
demo and it looks like I need to type my
password and I would like to show you
what we've built on top of cloud SQL
post yes BigTable pub/sub this is San
Francisco this is using the National
aerial imagery we are storing all of
this data we are not attaching PD disks
to VMs instead we're using managed
instance groups which are natively
reading cloud storage with a super-fast
layer so this is all of the us and this
is all native cloud storage reading and
reading to those imagery so as I
mentioned before and by the way if
you're really interested in how we did
all of that our CTO will be giving a
talk this afternoon at 5:20 and that's
IO 242 and we'll talk all about the file
system and using clouds or using cloud
storage as a scalable file system so in
this example I'm going I can look for a
number of different signatures that
we've trained tensorflow models on some
of the examples we have center pivot
irrigation here's a floating top oil
storage tanks orchards marinas
and in this example I'm going to look at
wind turbines and what we do is we slice
this entire layer this layer is
specifically aerial imagery and this is
only of the United States but then we
have other layers at different
resolutions and different bands of light
such as the Landsat I I mentioned
earlier and also planet who will be
giving the keynote part of the keynote
tomorrow and we can search over all of
those layers we we slice up into tiny
squares and we write a and this is all
done through through tensor flow models
and then if we click on on this area I
can see all of the different places on
this map that we've found a visually
similar object so here I can scroll in
and I can see and it looks like we found
visually similar wind turbines I can
click over to somewhere in California
and again I can find wind turbines a
pretty interesting use case is
center-pivot irrigation and again i'll
look over all of the earth and you think
how many people I could hire ten
thousand people and have them just
looking at scenes every day as they come
in they would probably commit suicide or
something else but in this case we can
easily use things like machine learning
to scale up to levels that you really
never could humanly so here we found
more crop circles and finally just an
example on planet planets are really
neat data say set planet is not
launching hundreds of millions of dollar
large satellites the way NASA would have
traditionally launched satellites
there's instead using really small
commodity-based cube sets and they'll
see the whole earth once a day at 3
meters for each pixel and so with planet
we have a number of things in this China
dataset that we've trained on and here's
one example
solar farms in China and I can look
everywhere in China and I can see
different places in China that are solar
farms and here's all the other results
that we found that are the top 500 most
similar searches so if I could switch
back to the presentation so where we're
going with this is things like
eventually being able to see in 2011 I
didn't see a wind turbine here and now
as we brought new imagery we all
assented see things like oh there's a
wind turbine this is a really neat type
of capability so as we're streaming in
data from all of these different
satellites looking down at the earth
we're constantly feeding those back into
models and aggregating results that our
customer help our customers really
answer hard problems just to other real
brief examples of the types of scenarios
our platform has to adjust for and how
there's not just one solution in this
example in with red green and blue
imagery it's quite hard to actually pick
out where the wind turbines actually are
however we can use from the European
Space Agency's Sentinel one satellite
there's something called synthetic
aperture radar on the satellite and we
collect this globally and excuse me
synthetic aperture radar emits into
Tech's radar signals those radar signals
can pass through clouds they can even
work at night and it gives you a
measurement of almost like a height
measurement on the ground and you can
see these vertical lines up and down
showing all of those wind turbines in
that field more of on the agriculture
side here it's quite challenging to
actually see the obe River in in Russia
you can see it's kind of dark and
there's there's definitely an area that
you think the river and vegetation is
there
however if we switch over to red edge
bands that are more like infrared you
can see the river and the vegetation is
highlighted in really really bright
yellow and then you can see water
channels so there's not one solution our
platform needed to be able to handle a
lot of different types of machine
learning questions that we were getting
we were asking of it and it's not not
every problem needs the same bands of
light or the same types of temporal
Cadence's and finally I just like to
wrap up where we're going at Descartes
is moving on to using things taking this
platform that we've built for these
internal use cases and making this
commercially available so we have all of
this imagery available that's been
cleaned and co registered and has a
really nice API to do analysis across
many different sources just with the
basic Python API and we hope that
showing you these types of things you
have ideas of scenarios I haven't shown
you and you would like to maybe build
models on your own without having to go
through all of these hassles so we're
hoping to make that right now this is in
private beta but we're hoping to
eventually open that up to the public
later this year so email us at hello at
descartes
if you're interested and I think with
that I'll turn it back over to Brett
really cool stuff it was I loved the
demo it's truly finding needles in a
haystack okay so let's talk about next
steps and wrap up a little bit as I
mentioned at the top we have beta
availability of Postgres on cloud sequel
starting very soon all users will have
access early next week watch for more
features coming
I got your feedback today you want a che
you want replication watch for big
features coming over the beta period a
couple points on our partner ecosystem
cloud sequel has a partner ecosystem
established we've added new partners for
the Postgres launched
day you see a number of business
intelligence software that have already
been certified with cloud sequel for
Postgres and if you're thinking to
yourselves I've got a data
transformation problem or I want to
understand how I can get my data where
it is today into cloud sequel for
Postgres the list of ETL partners is a
great place to start
all of these partners are on the cloud
sequel partner ecosystem website and
they're ready to help you with cloud
sequel for Postgres a few presentation
pics Tim mentioned IO 242 which is
happening later today I encourage you
all to attend that this afternoon we're
on day two of next you've got day three
tomorrow first pick on this slide is a
bit self-serving we've got another cloud
sequel presentation this one is focused
on optimizing performance and
availability in our my sequel product so
if you want to go deep into database
tuning see what we do as cloud sequel
see where you can get the configuration
that we actually use in cloud sequel to
soon our performance come to that talk
tomorrow morning at 11:20 I'm also
excited about building high-performance
micro services with kubernetes and a
look at big table specifically low
latency applications with respect to
personalized content BigTable again as
our no sequel database product so a few
presentation picks if you're still
finalizing what you're gonna go see this
afternoon and into tomorrow all of you
should take a look at cloud sequel for
Postgres by attending this conference
you receive cloud credits you can get
additional credits by signing up for the
tree trial link that you see on the
slide use those credits get familiar
with cloud sequel for Postgres give us
feedback and like Tim hopefully offload
a little bit of your work so you can
build a great application as well with
that thank you all for your time this
afternoon
[Music]
you